in five four three two one hello
everybody welcome to another episode the
genius brain podcast I'm sorry you just
you were you were nervous just a moment
ago and then she started getting into
character real questions I'm getting
ready
stop laughing at me David we have a
modem I feel you're [ __ ] nervous
energy right now it's gone so if you
guys watched my film goop this is one of
my cast members did an excellent
excellent job on the film by the way you
know the scene where you and Curtis are
with a Simone mmm-hmm and you guys are
if I wasn't there that day I was
sleeping cuz I was like my one day off
but you guys you guys were [ __ ] it
was a scene what you guys were arguing
and fighting
that was my first game that was your
first day dude that [ __ ] was in tents
and I didn't get to see that but I saw
it in the editing room afterwards on the
next day and actually made me cry that
[ __ ] was emotional as hell and that day
was stressful really phrasing stressful
seriously because okay it was gonna saw
someone professional I probably would
say it but there was back in fourths
with my start date and so I didn't
realize that day was my start date oh
really
so I showed up late first of all and
then it was where did we shoot like we
shot and we shot in a like in contact
that wasn't in Compton it was fine
anyways it's fine
so I hate traffic I got pulled over when
I was driving there cuz I almost ran a
red and this cop saw me like on the
verge of tears because I was like
stressed out it's like already late I
don't know anybody I look a mess
I was about to cry he's like just go I
was like thank you that's why the scene
was so [ __ ] good those because you
were stressed the [ __ ] out so stressed
but right now when did you I get to read
those lines before you before you got
the part maybe so wasn't much time like
you don't you don't get that really sit
with it then I think I don't know in
terms of casting I would have to be one
of the last people because it was I know
this Simone I mean you guys had rehearse
yeah for a bit but it was late lately
it's cuz this guy I got it
so also Cleef was the one that that uh
that uh yes oh good yeah no yeah cuz
Khalif is one who put me in touch her
Justin them that's wild
yeah yeah it's kind of crazy how that
film kind of came together like
everybody was just it was like picking
up the pieces for the parts for the film
just happened to work out really really
[ __ ] well I mean obviously like there
was a there was a huge auditioning
process but I think like when when
people fill the role correctly it was
just like that's it like yeah yeah we
don't we don't really have to think
twice about it there was another dude he
was a dancer from my area and you know
his role was very simple but he killed
it too he was he was the guy that was
like the quote-unquote studio producer
and he was he was cut it's funny when I
look back at the film too like I kept
watching the film versus being in it was
so different you know so when I was
watching I was like oh that's right I
did you you had a lot to do so I was
yeah that play probably blacking out
scenes just like I'm exhausted man we
had some [ __ ] stressful last [ __ ]
days though because there I wish they
would recorded some of the behind the
scenes because Justin and I got into so
many [ __ ] fights on set it was unreal
it was just stressful as [ __ ] just about
everything man just be it was because I
mean number one it was already a
stressful situation in mind you this was
as micro budget as micro budget guy you
you're you already knew the house that
you shot in was so [ __ ] disgusting
yeah there was people who actually lived
in that house it was crazy
amazing this place looks like trash
there's actually human beings Olivia you
son of a [ __ ] but there was this one
time where I think like we were shooting
for so long and we were so stressed out
it was the scene where Justin and I were
in the Justin and I were in the car so
he was directing the scene but it was me
and Justin's dad
so Justin and Justin's dad and I we were
kind of going back and forth on these
lines and Justin was so frustrated at
maybe I think it was because I
tired and we shot the scene before we
were on the roof screaming so my voice
was kind of al so just who was directing
the scene and he goes hey man like you
sound a little tired like fur cut per
couple okay
and I'm like already him saying that
made me pissed because I was tonight I
hadn't slept in like two days he goes
goes hey because you're acting the lines
too much be a little more natural and
I'm like ugh I'm gonna [ __ ] kill you
if I hit that I'm gonna [ __ ] kill you
man like I'm [ __ ] exhausted like I'm
literally gonna kill this guy
and he goes and and as we're shooting
like he just cuts he goes yo you're
overacting right now and I'm like what
the [ __ ] do you want like I'm like I'm
[ __ ] exhausted I was like I've been
away for two days just like you so like
I'm literally screaming at this flat the
top of my [ __ ] lungs and he's yelling
at me back and we just kind of chill out
a little bit we shoot the scene and
we're just standing next to each other
in like the most guy way possible he
just looks over he goes my bad move on
from it because it was so [ __ ] tiring
being on that film seriously oh it was
such a blur we don't even know if we
killed it or not in the script so many
times we didn't I didn't get too close
to it yeah too close to it so you don't
really know if it's a good performance
or not you know something I don't I
don't know if you're like this but
anytime I get good feedback from people
I don't believe it
really I do not believe it because this
is why I think I'm a really rational
person and I feel like it's people's
instinct to be like oh my god you were
so amazing so I'm like I don't trust you
do you do that to people though and when
don't what let me ask you exactly so let
me ask you something right let's say I'm
like one of your friends right I am your
friend but let's say all set money your
actor friends I show you something that
you really hate but you don't think is
good at all right but this person put
their heart and soul into it so I'm just
gonna I'm gonna be that and I want you
to act it out right now you're my friend
like we're close we've been friends for
years okay all right you just you just
got you just got done watching this [ __ ]
okay Oh Mona what did you think about it
oh my gosh okay I'm not gonna lie I've
seen you do better [ __ ] you [ __ ] I'm
close to you I'll tell you the truth it
sounds terrible
that's good though most people won't cuz
I don't know if you're the people you're
close to you don't trust really that's
kind of hard like just believe what I
mean I I trust them but it's like if if
somebody put their heart and soul into
it it's hard to watch like it's hard to
watch in this crash and burn right in
front of your face you know because I
have seen stuff that my friends have
showed me and I didn't really like it
but I was just I see I just said the
positive things that I enjoyed about it
do you say it could be better not it
could be better I've seen better or you
can definitely grow do you add something
like that into it or no I wonder because
I don't know if people genuinely want I
don't think they actually want right and
reacted we're so sensitive for sure I'm
like that too though like that too but
I'm skeptical of everybody I literally
don't believe it I asked my sister but
she's not an actor so I I trust that
she'll be honest but I'm like but see
when you ask people who aren't in your
craft and they give you an opinion about
stuff sometimes I'm like the [ __ ] the
unit right but if it's somebody that I
it's weird because it was somebody that
I lightweight respect I don't think I
want to hear too much [ __ ] from it but
if somebody I highly respect I want to
hear everything I feel right because I
think it's a balance of like what is
your position in life to have such a
staunch opinion about this piece because
if I gave let's say if I had a film and
then I showed I don't know like Scorsese
some [ __ ] actually problematic Scorsese
like I don't know like poems you know
right he did parasite and he he gave me
a list of stuff that I should correct I
would take that [ __ ] to heart I would
say thank you and I would fix all that
stuff yeah but if it was I don't know
let's say my brother right I go yo what
do you think is bad about the film and
he gave me his critiques I'll be like
thanks and then I'll go behind his back
and talk a lot of [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] on a
podcast yeah you know mr. nurse it's not
about science [ __ ]
how about that your nurse there we go
about to me I'm in nursing school so
what's up good cuz we talked about this
play what's this whole thing from from
acting to nursing what's right I know it
sounds like uhm so literally since I
graduated college my first
which is proven very useless I have been
taking prereq classes for nursing school
so it's always been something even
before I jumped into acting full-time
mm-hmm like I've always been like doing
it on the side doing a class oh my gosh
when we went to Sundance I was taking an
online class and I said oh really yes
I stayed up I remember our first night I
had to I don't know easily write a paper
or something
I stayed up till like 3:00 a.m. in my
room in that cabin finishing up my paper
and then the next day we went and did
press and everything how the hell did
you do it I have no [ __ ] idea I was
it's awesome I'm what do you mean you
don't do [ __ ] you do so much I'm joking
that's crazy that you were yeah but when
you are Sunday's I can't believe you
wrote a paper doing it in the airport
always be doing like I god I was so mad
at myself that day so the morning of all
the press was the day of the women's
March I remember I woke up early and I
was like I'm gonna go out you know
women's March I'll come back get ready
and we're out and they're like we're
doing press I was like [ __ ] I look like
[ __ ] but we're doing did you do the
woman's March that morning yeah that's
correct
I know Eunice did the woman's mind she
was so upset at me that I didn't do it
but I was like it was [ __ ] it was a
blizzard in the morning are you insane
the energy and there's so many people
you know and there's so many people you
all suffer together it's like unless
that energy was a heat dish I was not
gonna make you insane it was when I see
a blizzard I'm not exaggerating it was
you are exaggerating no it was an actual
blizzard that day David at nighttime
remember nighttime but this was the
morning then so the blizzard happened
and there was snow everywhere it was
cold as [ __ ] I think you were just hyped
up about just like the whole emotional
because it was cold as hell we're from
California so yeah that's a thing I
remember that was my first time seeing
actual snow falling never saw no I've
been to Big Bear which is like it's
man-made snow it's fake snow well not no
it's no no they're right now well when I
went to Big Bear no so I hadn't actually
seen snow falling from this guy so it
was so magical to me that's crazy I hate
the snow okay
I enjoy the snow for what it is like
it's fun but then like I'm not gonna
wake up at 6:00 a.m. in the morning
maybe that's what it was it was all the
my childhood dreams see it's definitely
is see it's definitely all that type of
[ __ ] - you know I I had a funny ass
conversation with somebody recently
about just because we're talking about
hype so when Black Panther first dropped
I remember how much everybody enjoyed it
right so Black Panther is on the Disney
oldest [ __ ]
hey this is Lizzie McGuire I think but I
saw Black Panther again recently I
didn't like it as much as the first time
really I didn't I didn't like it as much
Why What let me not jump down go away
it's not that the film wasn't good it
just wasn't as good as I remembered you
think it was a hype I think it was the
hype that got me because it was just as
good as like I think there's an average
like Marvel film mm-hmm but there wasn't
anything that made it like stand out
like in terms of like wasn't the acting
was it the way that it was film or a
shot if there wasn't anything that
really stuck out to me where I was like
oh this cuz I remember watching it being
like that was the best Marvel film I've
ever seen in my life
four times in theaters I don't know what
other movie I've seen four times in
theaters well that's what I'm saying
like I think also - I mean I watched
that twice in theaters - and I enjoyed
it both times and then when I want to
watch it again I'm like did I caught up
in the hype because I clearly remember
me enjoying that film way more than then
I did the third time but usually when I
really liked a film no matter how many
times I watch it I enjoy it cuz like
just the other day I watched
stepbrothers and I thought that [ __ ] was
[ __ ] hilarious I've never finished
that movie what I know I'd watch it on
TV and then change the channel and then
come back and then I missed a bunch and
then yeah you never liked it but did you
like it but I liked I just never
finished it how could you not finish it
is so [ __ ] fun on and you know cuz
they go on breaks is when I lived in oh
I'm not had cable you sure it's on
Netflix Nelson I could watch that [ __ ]
maybe I lost you tonight but I'm sorry
what kind of forever how could you say
that I don't know you know what I won't
be petty but I tell everybody about my
experience because that [ __ ] was one of
the most traumatized acting is literally
the most stressful job I've ever done in
my life I say it's the hardest job I've
ever done in my life ever and
a lot of jobs yeah it's it's ah you guys
this we read the blog post but you've
got to tell people about your whole
experience just because of how close
actually you I don't even know at the
end of the day how who knows how close I
was right maybe it wasn't even hmm I
don't know I think you isn't it crazy
just how different everybody's like one
thing can change your life like that
yeah it's yeah anyways here's the story
so it all started in my acting class our
teacher told us to do a monologue and I
couldn't find anything I liked so I
wrote a dang monologue and I wrote a
monologue for the character sure he like
I just made up my own monologue and I
was like okay did it in class loved it
killed it I was like this is me this
role fits like I love this girl
performed it it was great three months
later I get an audition and they didn't
call it black panther of course I don't
know what they called it I'm like this
sounds like Marvel this sounds and then
one of the characters was Tony like this
is [ __ ] Marvel yeah even the casting
office so I go in I'm like I put a lot
of effort into it I'm like [ __ ] yeah I
like the universe is playing chess with
me you know I made a move in the
universe is like yeah let's tango so
have my audition first audition I'm like
she did a good job they call me back as
soon as they did the callback they
already emailed my manager asking for my
availability
they're like she available these days I
was like oh my god oh my god second
audition goes well they call me back
again third one was with Kugler and
another producer I don't remember his
name
and I remember waiting for to go in the
room and hearing them listen to tapes of
other people I was like holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] you're auditioning for Black
Panther you wrote a monologue for this I
was like this is gonna make the best
story on Jimmy Kimmel like imagining
what I'm gonna wear to the freakin
premiere obviously didn't happen because
Here I am
did it happen I'm not Jimmy Kimmel I'm
[ __ ] Davis those podcast I'm sorry
I'm fine with it but good it was a good
learning lesson that I feel like it was
good for me to be like acting does not
give a [ __ ] about you and not in a bad
way but just don't get caught up and
always be grounded in your own self and
have your own [ __ ] in your own core
before you let the do for you because
you actually could you are you you we
booked it right like that was like
almost like this I guess I was like I
don't I never got a she's booked or
she's pinned or whatever no no it was
just the amount of auditions and ability
and her name and you know what at first
I was salty I was like damn I was really
invested that's my fault
y'all need something to be invested but
then after watching it she killed it
latisha right shut up she [ __ ] killed
it I was like how can I hate you yeah I
wouldn't hate the person I would just
hate life in general that's how I am
though that's how I that's how I heal my
wounds I hear so I just I can just bring
a little salt that's a little bit that's
crazy though because like that film did
so well it's so [ __ ] you could have
been you wouldn't be in nursing school
right now you wouldn't be nursing school
right now right there just thinking
about you know what you did you did what
I did when that [ __ ] was it that that
billion dollar lottery came out you know
when that huge lottery came on and
everybody was buying a lot of tickets it
was it was like a ridiculous and well it
might have been half a billion dollars
was like 500 million I think like two
people in Chino Hills one right but this
is what I did when that [ __ ] came out me
and my friends we all pulled a [ __ ] not
a [ __ ] ton of money like a few hundred
bucks together we bought a bunch a lot
of tickets right
I had already figured out what my life
was before I even want as if I was just
gonna win the lottery oh yeah you
planned my whole life look at you I
planned my whole life I was going to
leave this [ __ ] channel this channel
I was gonna put out a YouTube video that
said [ __ ] everything [ __ ] all this [ __ ]
[ __ ] all my subscribers no I'm kidding
I'm completely iced ill would have
continued YouTube I just would have D
monetized everything and you had more
fun and would have just been the
craziest [ __ ] videos everybody would
have seen oh my the most offensive [ __ ]
I will be dropping the n-word I'm
kidding now I'll be saying everything
dude I'll be going back to Sacramento
David like I would be saying no like
what are you gonna do take my money away
[ __ ] I don't think so I'm a [ __ ]
half a billionaire suck my nuts taxes
doesn't matter I could live off a solid
30 million for the rest of my life
that's good that's generational money
right there huh I should play the
lottery I never play I mean yeah but the
chances of winning is next to none a
buddy of mine from Seattle his mom owned
a gas station slash liquor store his
whole life and he said there have there
are customers who come in that he seen
since he was a kid that had been doing
the lotto for the past 30 years and they
still do it till this day and they still
haven't won he's probably just tradition
at that point you think they're really
genuine I guess but that money like if
you if you're trying to win big money
you spend a hefty amount really yeah
it's a lot more expensive I forget how
much it is but it's not like a dollar
it's it's it gets it racks up a little
bit black I really planned out my whole
life man like I just what would you do
ooh tell me your budget yeah half a
million not half a million Oh first off
did I throwing away my kitchen cuz I
ain't never cooking ever again yeah then
like I'm bugging people making me food
number two you mean a jet that's
different I would hire a chef and we are
conversations about food number two I
would have an in-house masseuse giving
me a massage every [ __ ] day for the
rest of my life I in pain no I don't
give a [ __ ] I have millions of dollars
so I have IVA in I have a masseuse I'll
have a bunch of dogs because I'm not
gonna clean up the poop you see dogs
dogs okay cuz I'm not gonna clean up the
poop hire somebody to come you up
somebody else can clean up the poop I'm
definitely gonna get a house for sure
mm-hmm other than that I'll be traveling
all the time I won't be at home only be
at home I'll retire my parents do by the
way my parents my god this is
my parents I'll retire than this [ __ ]
but I just I just would do the same
thing that I'm doing now I just wouldn't
worry you know saying cuz I'm I do have
this thing in the back of my mind that
everything that I've earned up into this
point will be taken away from me why do
you feel that way because I grew up so
broke right that's that that was that
was the the status quo it was like being
broke so I think if you I think for me
because I grew up so poor that's always
in the back of my head and that could
always happen again so it's like like I
never really spend money like that I
know a lot of people who have made a lot
of money I know they spent a lot of it
and they don't have a lot now like I
know people now who um I see what they
have like it's like number one I know
how much you make because we're in the
same business I know what you do I know
for a fact that you shouldn't be walking
around with the [ __ ] LV backpack and
also the [ __ ] and a Rolly on your wrist
cuz for a fact you don't have that money
in your baby yeah yeah okay interesting
you're making me think of something you
said you have this fear of it being
taken away yeah hmm do you feel like are
you afraid of that happening for sure oh
that's that's like a perpetual theatre
that I always live with because I don't
know I think it's because also the
industry that I'm in it's it's stable
yeah maybe it's not even the industry
that's unstable it's my feelings that
are unstable about it right so if I was
in it to win it and it didn't really
matter how long it was gonna take and I
was kind of married to the fact that
there's a high chance that I could be
poor as long as I love doing this art
yeah then then yeah I don't think it
would bother me as much but the the
thing that really bothers me on the back
of my mind is the fact that my parents
are still working you know that I'm
pointing and married I might have a kid
and all this stuff bothers me and I
think when it comes to creativity when
you have these responsibilities it does
it does kind of like take away from it
some people say it's my motivation right
it's like it's my motivation if I have a
kid I have all these responsibilities it
makes me want to work harder so they
don't have to worry for me it's the
opposite it's like I also want to be a
Family Guy so it's like you know if I'm
an actor I'm always on call and I'm away
how can I be a really great father I
don't give a [ __ ] when anybody else says
it's like I if you know they're like I'm
an actor I'm around from
are you really though like you're not as
available as other people are you take
them with you I guess but I don't even
want to take my kids with me [ __ ] them
you know I want them to have a stable
life to that I want them to know I want
them to know what it's like to stay at a
certain place develop relationships and
have friends have lifelong friends cuz
that's so important okay so you probably
think you know this I was born in
Nigeria moved her and I was 12
yeah and the reason I kept asking about
are you afraid of blah blah
growing up my so my parents moved to the
states first before me and my sister
came here so we were raised by aunts
grandparents my grandma was balling like
rich rich rich so I never felt broke I
was like there's life it's good yeah and
then I moved to the States are they oh
no no no y'all enriched so it's like
one-bedroom apartment with my mom and my
sister you know and so I think seeing
both sides of it has giving me this
weird
maybe not weird but it's giving me this
different view where I feel like I've
seen I've lived in both situations and I
don't feel afraid of using I don't know
maybe maybe I don't have that much to
lose to but it's like I'm like I know
I'll be fine in both situations yeah so
it's like I'm like huh yeah I guess like
for me it's not so much a matter of
feeling fine or okay I think it's just a
matter of I I know what life is like
when you don't have money and how much
stress it brings that that is something
that is just a fact of life especially
when you have to take care of other
people too my dad and my mom fought so
much when their business wasn't doing
well and I could see that now as it as a
young person I mean as an older person
but as a young person I couldn't see it
I couldn't see why they would fight over
the dumbest [ __ ] it's because they're
always afraid that number one are we
gonna pay our bills on time is our house
can they be taken away can we pay these
credit card bills can we pay the can we
keep the lights on at the house and the
store can my kids go on these field
trips can they do all this stuff so and
I see it in my own life too like when I
when when I was kind of volatile in my
career and I didn't know where to go
Maryland Maryland I got into a lot of
fights and it was because I was unstable
I was so emotionally unstable and
anything that she would do it wasn't a
big deal but I would get upset and that
actually allowed me to empathize
with my parents a little more it's like
now I know why they were so they would
fight so much when we were younger and
then when we started going into like
lower middle class which isn't that
great itself it's like oh they fired a
little less cuz now they're not worried
about you know is my are my two kids
gonna have a meal the next day so that's
the that's the fear that I have is like
the stress that money brings and even
even friends now who decide to go into a
career they make their last minute
career choices or career flips and
they're like yeah I appreciate the art
and it's great I'm doing what I love but
and they figure out like oh I can't do a
lot of the things I want because I don't
have money it's like that's that's what
money does for you it actually gives you
freedom it gives you options and give
you choices and that's the thing that
I'm afraid is gonna be taken away now
mind you I don't really live that
lavishly but I do understand like the
power of the money has yeah in seven
rings all right
ariana grande yeah she said those people
who say money can't solve problems don't
have enough money that is - yo man some
people say that [ __ ] no and it [ __ ]
makes me mad it's like you rich [ __ ]
you should you're like yes like money
everybody who has money says the same
[ __ ] they got money doesn't buy you
happiness it makes you a little happier
though yeah it gives you a you like I
understand what people mean like money
is not the physical things right and
it's true but it's I want this coming
from a point of privilege I want to hear
that from a [ __ ] North Korean
military survivor I want this guy to be
like money doesn't make you happy at all
I wanted Imogen I bought into say that
when the gun to the back of his head I
don't want to hear that [ __ ] from
somebody who has money and things are
popping it's like it's easy for you to
say that cuz shit's popping off for you
man like things are really really good
for you that's why I also want people to
be careful too sometimes when I hear
like these youtubers like they come on
and they're they're trying to give the
sage as wisdom advice about money and
being happy it's like you're a
millionaire people people you can't
relate to these people it's like you
were a millionaire when you were 14
years yeah and you want to tell you want
to teach people how to deal with their
anxiety and their problems it's like
shut the [ __ ] up like sit down like you
don't know [ __ ] I'm gonna play devil's
advocate yeah because I give you 50
million dollars right now I'll be the
happiest person on earth
and we'll be and everybody's getting a
car I'll be like a [ __ ] car - she pays
taxes on the cars I didn't know that she
doesn't owe so when you get the car you
don't you have to pay the taxes on it
though it's not gonna give you a house
and then exactly so you still gotta pay
the taxes okay but this is the thing so
all your problems are now gone right or
some of them okay problems gone in two
years you still got problems oh I won't
you know why cuz money fixes all now the
funny thing is I I know that I will
never be alive along enough to do
everything that I want to do so if I do
have that financial freedom like number
one I'll be helping out a [ __ ] ton of
people that's the first thing right off
the bat I joke about a lot of things but
I I because I know how much money can
help people I already know how much
great I want to do with it right now
whether it's like charity work or
something else but I'll definitely
devote my life to helping other people
because if I received like this odd
amount of money for no [ __ ] reason -
no work of my own I'm definitely gonna
pay that forward
I don't need [ __ ] five hundred
million dollars to live but I know other
people who do need that money
so definitely I'd probably do that Bill
Gates thing where he's gonna give up all
of his all of his wealth by the time he
dies something is his kids are fine look
at the life they've been living the
schooling they've got like their
children they don't need a frickin
fortune I heard I heard that when he
somebody I forgot somebody calculated it
out but they're like somebody said that
Oh like Bill Gates is gonna snub his kid
because he's only giving them a percent
and I'm like you know what a percent of
a gajillion dollars is could you yeah
it's it's still like I forgot what the
sum of money was I mean I'm just gonna
say and I've seen him out but it was
like I don't know he was gonna give a
kid like 150 million it's like it was
like a percent or like a happy person so
I don't think people realize how wealthy
Bill Gates is but he's gonna give up a
bulge or do as well but after he passes
I think his kids are gonna % which is
like a kajillion so they're pretty much
if I won the lottery I'm not telling
anybody oh I tell people I'm not telling
I tell people I hate asking you but I
have bodyguards because I'm rich I would
happen
I would have them murdered in a slow I
hate these people they don't need to be
alive but still everybody I can imagine
people I haven't talked to in years
hey I'm like no I don't want anybody to
know that wouldn't even stress me out
though like if people I haven't talked
to in years like yo man I'm going to
financial problems like I heard your
money it'll stress me out I think about
like family members so I was polluted
forever you know what maybe it wouldn't
it would stress me out but then I'll be
like oh I would love to tell them to
[ __ ] themselves like I would love that
[ __ ] I would love for people to come out
the woodwork and be like you know what
hey David like remember when I spotted
you that fire that's cool let me give
you that five back dawg yeah with
interest I'll give it to you in pennies
no you don't even worry about that [ __ ]
like I love that because there are
people I know who I'm gonna give the
money to and then everybody else is like
I'm gonna give the charity cuz these
people are way worse off than they were
so you have your problems I get it but
if we don't have a relationship like
that you're not getting any of this
[ __ ] money I'm gonna give it to other
people who I don't have a relationship
who aren't asking who need it well
actually need it yeah yeah I don't have
a problem with that [ __ ] that's like
less like back in the day when people
have told me like cuz I always I always
drove an SUV and they said don't don't
have an SUV because everybody's gonna
ask you to move things I was like you're
right but I can also just say [ __ ] no
I've never had a problem with that [ __ ]
no yeah it's like hey man I gotta move
stuff this weekend that's cool and let
me give you the number two u-haul bro
they got trucks like [ __ ] I need to be
more like you I think the older I'm
getting the more I am it's like it's so
easy to say no no because I don't care
because I have I know like the important
people in my life it's like even now
when I have this I have this wedding
coming up right and there are people who
assume that they're coming there it's so
funny when people assume that they're
coming to my wedding it's the most
hilarious [ __ ] deal and they go like
yo man I can't wait for your wedding I
was like I know those pictures are gonna
be dope when you see it man like [ __ ] do
you dress it in a moment right there
yeah just like that because like that
well because I'm uh how I joke either
way so they kind of get it but it's
weird that like why am I gonna paint
like a hundred something bucks for your
[ __ ]
I don't even know you like that bro and
even if we're like decent friends decent
friends don't get invited to the wedding
because it costs money right and I hate
weddings
I [ __ ] hate weddings
I hate big way I'm not gonna date I made
my smallest wedding I hate getting
invited to weddings I hate dressing up
to weddings I hate all that [ __ ] it's a
waste of money to me and it's a waste of
time because I can't imagine spending
it's hard for me just morally speaking
just to spend $50,000 on myself for what
it's not just on you though right take
for the family is like what my mama
suggested that she goes watch you just
go to the courthouse which I would love
to do but I think you know I think about
both families at this point but Mariel
and I just had a conversation where I I
told that she was so stressed out about
this whole wedding situation now I was
like you know what you just said a
number of people that you wanted the
wedding right if it's 50 people 25
people 10 you let me know and then I'll
work that number out and if people get
hurt that they're not invited to this
wedding it's a personal exactly that's
your issue dude it's my [ __ ] day
right and they're like well I'm not
gonna invite you to my wedding I
appreciate that
there are people who make it to be have
you ever been in that situation where I
don't know where there's a friend and I
guess like it's like a loose friend like
you're not even that close to them and
they'll be like talking about the
wedding plans like you know I would have
invited you it's like I never said I
wanted to go [ __ ] I this happened a
couple of times like yo man like I
really would like you to go I'm like dog
I don't like my friends getting married
this year she's like the first one of
our group oh [ __ ] April see it's
exciting when it's the first one but
after you go to about 30 40 I apparently
have a lot of friends like y'all would
love for you I got it was gonna give
speeches to uh yes and I say no they're
[ __ ] dumb it's like why would I good
was I haven't I barely know you [ __ ]
and push I'm alive you're great already
yeah but you don't want somebody like me
to do it unless it's gonna be a funny
wedding because there's families there
right and I'll do like a whole stand-up
comedy bit and it'll be really funny but
at the same time it's like I mean I've
married a lot of my close friends you
can marry people yeah I mean what do
they call it yeah you could get it
you just go online and just [ __ ]
order it it's it's that simple you could
become an ordained minister online five
seconds it's like I think it cost like
five dollars yeah I want to do this you
should like if I think a lot of people
because they're not they're not hyper
religious they don't want the
traditional like Christian or Catholic
wedding yeah that they just need to get
ordained so they need somebody who is
ordained to actually sign off on it you
just go online get your license or
whatever and like five five bucks and in
five minutes and then you get and you're
done it's crazy you oh I can see
marrying people I feel like that'd be so
fun so I married my really close friends
Barton geo Kacey and TIFF and I also
married my buddy Tim and Gia and then I
yeah so I married them as well - it was
a good experience
yeah nice you you enjoyed I mean it's
pretty fun if you really care about the
person it's it's easy because you
already have a backstory so the weird
part is when people ask me to marry them
and I don't we know them it's like I'm
not I don't have any cute stories about
you I don't want to get to know you to
tell these stories it's like you do so
many things I don't know do I'm thinking
about what we were talking about before
and then like with all the businesses
and then forget a minister what yeah I I
was a youth minister for a couple years
before I I started doing all this stuff
so my dad's a pastor and then he started
up a church in Sacramento and while he
was there I was a Bible study teacher
and s which is so funny that I say now
there's nobody would ever believe me
but I was a Bible study teacher then and
then from then on they they kind of lost
their youth minister and they couldn't
find one so during that time I was gonna
go to seminary school and become an
interim so I was like an interim pastor
so I was in in-between going to seminary
school it's like David in the other
world
yeah so I I wanted to do it and I did it
for about I said like a year and a half
maybe almost couple years and at the end
of the day I found it I [ __ ] hated
kids I was like you know what kids [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you man you know what God loves
you but I barely do I really do like I
love kids there was a few kids I really
liked but it was just hard dealing with
some of these personalities
I think like the very difficult part
about being a religious leader is that a
lot of people don't know this but
there's up really which is so I think
the irony is in there because a lot of I
found out through other pastors that the
suicide rate for new ministers is really
high because of the stress level which
is so funny because religiously speaking
like suicide is there's a system normal
sitting like you don't go to heaven if
you do that but it's because of the
stress level is so [ __ ] high I'm
gonna sound very naive but are they
stressed about well number one when
you're when you're a pastor you're
you're not just giving sermons right so
it's like you are also highly involved
in the community number two if anything
goes wrong in the church it's your fault
if anything goes right it's all glory to
God so sure you get no credit
you're literally a servant of God and
you know that that in itself is a very
beautiful thing and I think this is for
a lot of youth ministers who are little
mortal and not just youth minister just
ministers who are a lot more traditional
there's a lot of other ministries now
where you see like these Rockstar
pastors which is very odd to me just
because some of these rock star pastors
they have seven-figure incomes which is
I don't morally speaking that doesn't
[ __ ] make sense to me cuz there's
people in your congregation that can't
there are barely getting by and then
you're walking out with the [ __ ]
escalated [ __ ] like that like I don't
really [ __ ] subscribe to that
[ __ ] so there's there's there's that
part of it too where unless you're in
that type of realm where you're doing it
for glory to yourself there's a lot of
stress involved in it so a lot of like
youth ministers I think they need a lot
of therapy they need a lot of love
because they're so used to giving
that's all you ministers do they give to
their congregation to give to their
flock their sheep or whatever and they
keep giving giving giving giving but
there but what did they get the take
that makes sense it's true who does the
pastor go to talk to exactly their
mentor pastor who does that person go to
talk to you God exactly God you know
you're talking to God and the gods like
not saying anything it's like Dan you
mad to get [ __ ] stressed out like I
remember just listening to some of the
[ __ ] that some of these youth kids
would go through and it's it's
understandable because they're young
right but then I have to be built to be
dealing with this every day for the rest
of my life and that was the hard part
like
I had to deal with some of these kids
who are these rich spoiled kids talking
about their [ __ ] problems about them
being addicted to oxycontin and [ __ ]
it's like like it was just one kid kid
his hot trash he's probably a good adult
now but then just if you're ever if you
just happen to come by this podcast kid
you were trash then and if you're still
like that now you're [ __ ] hot trash
now God barely loves you so he he was
addicted to oxycontin which number one
is a rich for rich [ __ ] kids drug
right he decided to steal from his
parents money wise and stuff just so he
could buy more pills right and then he
robbed his cousin's house so he could
buy some more [ __ ] for his drug problems
again and his parents because he was
going through all these lawyer fees
because he was getting the big [ __ ]
trouble with all the like the narcotics
and drugs he [ __ ] like that
his parents had to hire a bunch of
lawyers to keep him out of jail and his
parents were going bankrupt his Christ
for doing and I had to deal with this
[ __ ] and he's like Tom well I got
problems like [ __ ] that's a problem you
bought on yourself [ __ ] like don't talk
that was like the poorest person in that
church because I was like the minister
but he was all rich kids so it's like I
don't give a [ __ ] about your problems
and everybody's coming to you with their
problems yeah it's like I got problems
it's like you you're rich I don't want
to hear this [ __ ] money solves
everything everybody has problems I'm
not I'm not trying not to be empathetic
but it's like you know you you're you're
barking up the wrong tree yeah you know
it's like these are problems that you
brought into yourself nobody told you
and take oxycontin dumb [ __ ] don't you
learn I don't know oh yeah
I've definitely had this thing where
I've I like to try anything and
everything possible try twice what am I
had a boss it was like every time you
try something new try it twice for two
years I think that's damn I was a TA for
fourth grade oh how was that loved that
job I think this is what it's like to
wake up and enjoy going to work you know
I had like weird situations they like
John like with kids I feel like
elementary school problems are kind of
hard because you're a lot more involved
in these kids lives I never felt had
anything that made me feel like oh [ __ ]
I don't know my class is also amazing
though oh really
they were freaking amazing so you you
definitely were [ __ ] you see that video
clip
that one kid no this cute they were all
doing it activity and this this is one
little badass kid it's not funny but
it's funny cuz I got mad but I was
laughing my ass off what do you play but
he was like [ __ ] you [ __ ] it's just
little kid and then he goes she goes hey
hey hey watch your language right he
goes [ __ ] you know oh no I don't have to
do with that yeah so that's that's
that's the type of [ __ ] I see something
I like about myself though I think I'm a
very nice person but I can be very firm
and stern and so like I will not take
your [ __ ] I I can be that person so
I think at least my experience with kids
even in high school I did this thing
called I already forgot what it's called
but every lunch break our senior year
we'd go and teach art to like kids and I
remember my partner she could never get
a grip on them they were always like
just being disrespectful and like the
energy I'm gonna take into that room
he's like I am NOT here to [ __ ] play
games yeah and so I don't know if my
experience has been good also you had
that [ __ ] African you just try to
handle these no no I did not leave
Nigeria yo my friend my zone my best
friend he's a he's Rwandan right name is
gobble his dad used to his dad would
tell me the most mortifying [ __ ]
stories about his childhood cuz that's
the funny thing like when you have a
parent who's an immigrant you just never
allowed to complain because no matter
what you go through they they always
went through things way harder so this
is really my so hard only reason why and
I'm not trying to say that gobbles dad
is lying
I walked 20 miles Kerry what it's like
bro yo you went to school in London
that's the [ __ ] funny [ __ ] let you
start to realize like sometimes like I
know they probably went through some
tough [ __ ] but they're definitely adding
a little sauce on that [ __ ] I mean like
this one would talk about like David I
used to get by feet beat every day I'm
like why would you get your feet beat
why why right here's like they would
take me on the floor and they would hit
my feet until it
and then like you see his mom he's
rolling around exactly the [ __ ] exactly
like you would doubt me he's like funny
ass [ __ ] stories about him like that
that 20 mile walk [ __ ] every parent
every immigrant mother if you're African
Korean it doesn't matter my dad my dad
would talk about he said that he used to
have to like hike up a mountain just to
get some water I'm like there was a
convenience store
I thought that's where you were [ __ ]
why do you have to go up this mountain
there's not exist a melon it's like you
like I had to go to a mountain and water
up the little instant noodle cup just so
I feed every day he's like I had a
donkey I said what is this dog shaman
and I would take a donkey on my back
because I felt bad for the donkey and my
grandma this is I think it's true I feel
like my parents and grandparents and me
is kind of eclectic like the offbeat
Africans but my grandma says she had a
pet goat you should kill that good eat
it she's like no no I cook studies like
crazy stories man that's like my god she
told me that you had a goat he's like
she had a goat I might believe that [ __ ]
though well gobble told me what cuz I
was supposed to go to Rwanda with him
but this is like during the time that I
really popped off on YouTube and so I I
had to I couldn't new phone is yes so I
ignored him I was like [ __ ] you guys
no I just couldn't I had to make a
choice is like well I can go on vacation
for three weeks like this just start
hitting these videos and during this
time like you sound like a lifelong it
was popular it was these comedy videos
that we're really helping my career so I
had to make a choice and not go but this
fool told me like he was like dude when
I was there like they had me eat goat
every [ __ ] day he said he was so sick
a [ __ ] goat and it was to the point
like he said that he would he ate some
of this goat and he's like when he was
in the more rural areas like when they
could kill a [ __ ] goat for you it
means some [ __ ] but then he was like dog
this goat was so chewy eat this chewy
yes goat that's yes and he couldn't spit
it out because he didn't want to be
disrespectful so he had to eat the sorry
ESCO but he said he drink he drank a lot
of Fanta and ate a
bunch of goat that's all he did he said
like Fanta is like the [ __ ] in Africa he
was like everybody either drinks Fanta
or water
coke or water or some [ __ ] like that he
goes that's really about it but he said
that soda was cheaper out there than it
was for water or wherever he was they're
not so problematic isn't that crazy
it's piled that that Fanta is like the
[ __ ] or it's like fat or bearish on that
want a Fanta our beer so it's like it's
not even water or beer that's crazy
Fanta that's in there [ __ ] well
that's so problematic to me yeah I'm uh
it's even in Korea I heard I mean
haven't been there in a while but people
said like it certain parts like soju
like the liquor is cheaper than a bottle
of water so like people isn't that
[ __ ] what company was it was in
Nestle I hope I'm not like was it label
if I say [ __ ] that's not real I think it
is a libelous [ __ ] all the time no but
but the whole you know my brain is not
working uh the water let's come back to
this Nestle and water Bailey being a
[ __ ] boy with the whole Flint thing
there we go um yeah so man I'm telling
this story so badly but apparently Flint
or Michigan or wherever the government
there has a deal with Nestle and they
nestle started charging people for water
after X amount of really min passed and
it's like you're not even giving us like
access to drinkable water and you're
charging us for water now is that Flint
water things still at issue right now
yeah I mean they don't trust the people
they don't trust the government and how
why am I supposed to trust you how come
they don't have water what so what's the
issue it's not a bit they have water but
the pipes so they didn't either
update the pipes or they didn't take
care to filter the water that is going
to the people and so it had really high
concentrations of the contaminants yeah
yeah and it's like you're literally
killing your population that's crazy to
would be most like I guess like
technology technologically advanced
we're supposed to be like a shining
light at first world and yeah we can't
even get water to people it's ridiculous
and I think about it's kind of like
Flint New Orleans
what's in common black people let's be
honest
there's a whole bunch of white people
there you think that would have happened
I know what you know did you hear about
the whole issue with so target has his
brand called the honeypot I saw that you
see that she read the article I saw the
heading today but oh so I'm forgetting
her name but actually let me look that
up cuz I want to give her some [ __ ]
credit but a honeypot is a is a brand of
like feminine care products right and
this in his black-owned specifically
black female owned right her name is
Beatrice Dixon which is the most non
black name of her in my line that's not
like an old white lady sounds like a
1920s old white lady that's [ __ ]
crazy but she started up this uh this
feminine Karen line right and it does
super well at Target like people [ __ ]
love it rave reviews but she did a video
where she said let's see but it was
something along the lines and it was by
the way number one it was harmless and
it doesn't mean anything but you know
how when you say something people like
to twist it but she says that you know
one of the she really appreciated that
target picked up her brand because it's
great that they like young black women
can see that you could have a successful
business right it's great for young
black women to see and so for some
reason a bunch of why people took that
as oh I don't want to support this
racist product because apparently it's
only for black people it's like yo [ __ ]
that's not what she [ __ ] said like
people this is all lives matter crowd
it's it's such a it was so and you know
at first you know sometimes like media
likes to exaggerate things right but
then people were giving cited examples
of these reviews and apparently like her
product originally on target had I may
fix the issue now it like it's all five
stars now so before it had five stars
but after people were upset about it
they put they were giving it one star
review saying that her comments were
super racist that it was it was very
unnecessary or some [ __ ] like that
people really offended and then her I
think it went down like two stars or
some [ __ ] like that but it was so
ridiculous I'm like how did you take
that as that how is that an attack on
you how is that racist - exactly
okay that's that's its own topic yeah
you want to unpack what even racism
means but it's like literally saying I
want to
well if my community means I'm racist
brah
yeah cuz III I genuinely feel let's say
if that was like I don't know like an
Asian or Mexican person and they said
that like I create this because I want
my kids to know or you know like a young
Asian women to know that you know you
could have a business I don't think
anybody would have been like yo this is
a racist product because they only want
to put it to Asian people I don't think
that would have been the case I really
don't because that's a very odd that's a
very odd take away from that statement
you know this climate the political
climate even though it feels like a
regression in some ways has been good
because it's kind of just opened the
screen on everybody that you think was
you know and it's like kumbaya
post-obama
like society it's like no the fact that
that's happening in this day and age
like it's like what but I love that the
end to that story the article I saw at
least was that her sales went all the
way up yeah because it was a few I think
cuz what happens is just like a few
annoying loud people don't represent a
majority of the community right because
you know if people have like a certain I
feel like what happened was is that they
bought this product and they didn't know
that a black woman was running the
company how is it that you find out and
you are so heated by that it's like I
refuse they just took the tampon out the
[ __ ] window I don't give a [ __ ] but
named Beatrice Dixon
Beatrice that's probably why she I know
it's because of her name I just manga
unpacked the mystery right now
you should be a detective I should do it
like you're Blue's Clues coward they
heard the name Beatrice Dixon and they
were like she is an old white racist
lady I support they thought she was
gonna wear a t-shirt with a confederate
flag on it so weird it was a weird move
though for those few people that that
said that it was racist that's a very
weird thing to say I even understand it
like I'm like where are you coming from
I mean part of me wants to interview
them yeah like sit them down it's like
well why do you think it's racist it's
big III guess what the what where I read
from the article and also what I'm
assuming is that when they heard that
they what they heard is this product is
only for black women and that's nowhere
near what she was saying which is such
an odd thing races races like the
hottest topic right right now especially
over on Twitter and it's it's weird
because I see I see it go to like the
extremes now I get and also to like the
most extreme cool are the most vocal
that's it I mean they everybody here is
I'm the most exactly so kind of it kind
of tastes things in a weird way too and
I remember reading for you when we had
this conversation back in the day like
you were telling me like growing up
because you know you you you came here
when you were 12 from Nigeria like it
was you it was either your parents or
you had a hard understanding of like
like black plight like in the States
because it wasn't something that you
were a part of I remember conversations
did she yeah that was me that's
definitely on me yeah it's because I
mean so you come from this place where
everybody looks like you right mm-hmm
and even though everybody looks like you
white supremacy is still a thing because
of how pervasive American media is so
even though you're living in a place
where everybody looks like me there's
still that's my hair is not straight oh
my hair is not flowing there's because
you see these posters of beauty
that's why skin bleaching is still an
issue and you know in certain African
guys I heard about that [ __ ] like in
like in like it was it called like
Jamaica or some [ __ ] like that it's
still a thing and it's like how is this
still a thing where everybody black
because everything the media and we hold
Americans okay let me rephrase we hold
white Americans up to this pedestal
anyways so I came here and that was just
cranked up times too because one I'm
trying to understand what black people
are going through I wasn't even trying
to understand I'm 12 let's be honest I'm
like nah but then you realize that I
live in a country where black people
have been subjugated and I'm coming
fresh so now I have to deal with the
repercussions of this when I haven't
grown up with it so it was it really it
was traumatic I will say traumatic
having to understand like oh [ __ ] I fall
into this I'm not just like innocent
come from you know my my life or
whatever just because like even though
you know you're Niger
that's not what the rest of the world
sees I see you as black exactly I'm
black yeah I think it's funny but
there's I think it's getting better now
especially as new generations come up
but there has historically been a
distinction that Africans make between
themselves and black Americans oh I see
I saw that [ __ ] so much you know I had
explained that [ __ ] to Mariel because
she didn't understand she was I was like
I forgot what it was what we were
watching what what you were listening to
but she didn't understand like the
conversation or the nuance between it
now I was like oh you don't know that
like traditional African people they
don't see themselves as lacking they're
not they're not black Americans they are
African and arguably so I've heard some
the most racist [ __ ] from African people
and how they talk about like black
Americans have I every single like
racist [ __ ] that you heard like a white
person say I've heard like an African
person saying about black people saying
that they're lazy they don't work hard
and this is a thing so you think think
about the person who thinks this way
yeah you're like I'm an African man blah
blah blah I'm different
once you step out on the street you are
a black man in America
full stop you will get shot sorry I
shouldn't maybe that's too heated but
you the police is gonna look at you the
same way you're walking in the shop
they're gonna look at you the same way
they don't know that you're African
you're a black presenting man the end of
story
so I think and I hope it's getting
better that as these new generations
come up there is more of a marriage
between these two communities and I
think it's been - for too long it's been
disjointed and that's why it's hard to
see that marriage is because like and
this is my opinion on it because I think
people don't want to also like give up
their culture just because somebody says
you are this because you and even if
keep your culture but why are you
looking down on the other yeah I think
the looking down part is the part that
we could get rid of but I think it's
it's hard because they understand that
this is how it is in the States
and it's they would still want to have
their leg up they'd still want to keep a
piece of themselves right but it's hard
to keep a piece of yourself when people
keep stripping it away from you no
matter how quote-unquote African you are
or how Asian you are people still want
to strip that and take that away from
you so what that happens that it but
what I see from that is that
just the only way that they can make a
distinction up for themselves is for
them to just lash out it's like so a
dream about it right yeah because it's
like they're just so upset you know so
it just it just kind of sucks to is just
like no even if you like you said like
when you walk out in the street what
people see they don't see African mail
they see black mail yeah so it's like
you're still gonna go through the same
flights it's just a matter of you know
are you gonna be human enough to
empathize with that situation because
when you come into this country or just
like you go into any country you you
have to understand that there are set of
rules in history that came here before
you step yep yeah yeah and I understand
from both sides I've had my own share of
problematic thinking for sure because I
mean this is the thing you come here at
least as an immigrant that's all I can
speak to and it's like I still think
this there is so much opportunity in
this [ __ ] country there's so much
opportunity it is not perfect at all but
there's so much opportunity and I get it
you come here you see what people can do
what you can achieve and okay even
though the white picket fence thing
might be a false policy but still
there's possibility here and then if
when you feel like there are home born
people who aren't taking advantage of
that I can see it being like why why are
you not excelling when you have all
these available to you but then you have
to take into consideration you have been
born and you've been raised in a country
that either has not made those
accessible to you or you may just not
even even know about those things
because of you know the situation you're
born into you know it's interesting just
because I I know inches from my personal
experience of there's so many like
parallels to like African like culture
and Asian culture in terms of like
academia like so many I know like
African prayers really push their kids
to be a nurse or be in the medical field
just like Asian kids it's kind of crazy
like how many like African nurses there
are like that in New York there's a lot
not here yeah there's a lot that like
maybe push him into like like the
medical I was like oh [ __ ] that's the
most Asian thing I've ever heard in my
life
also like the [ __ ] American struggle
story since like the same [ __ ] the same
way you beat your kids is the same wage
me will beat the kids too it kind of
runs parallel yeah I remember the last
time my mom hit me I didn't talk to her
talking to you how'd that work out for
you it worked out great no cuz I
remember I got too old for this I was
like 14 I'm too old for this 14 was the
last time you were hit the last time I
was it was last year
I still got my ass beat that's [ __ ]
crazy no but I parents this is the thing
remember I said earlier they're kind of
like eclectic Africans mm-hmm we weren't
she really didn't beat us that often and
I think that's part of what it was I was
like what yeah and also my parents came
to the States before I did so I was
raised for a good chunk of my life my
aunts grandparents blah blah blah
so I come and I'm like what yeah anyways
um
story time my sister had a cat when she
was young and this cat got stuck in a
tree this isn't Legos and my parents
called the fire department and it's like
you don't do that in Nigeria like they
came and they're like are you joking all
this right cat and they left so using
that as an example of showing just kind
of offbeat like hipster Africans what
was your parents do they were
journalists so they worked for Vanguard
and they met my dad was a sports
journalist he traveled with the superego
Suzanne I did those are the Nigerian I'm
the Nigerian soccer team and then my mom
she had a column called the lipstick
column and she got to just write about
whatever I guess and so they met so your
parents were already kind of artsy so
exactly it only makes sense that
transferred over to you I guess I have
my blog so that makes me feel like oh
maybe I actually saw your blog before
before you came on you're actually
pretty good at that [ __ ] Thanks writing
is great your photos are great to thank
my sister Oh pixel that's dope
although all those photos on a Google
pixel Google picks oh man they look
great thanks
that looks [ __ ] crazy do you live
with your sister I do it's really nice
I've been spoiled I don't have a real
roommate or I guess she's a roommate but
it's family you know yeah cooks and she
cooks for the house it's not like this
is my food this is your food it was like
a family tapas it's so nice that's
pretty so nice it was just to do she
went oh god she just told me so many
times I keep forgetting
she does digital marketing for NBC Oh
hope so she's kind of in the I guess
like TV well if it's NBC I guess it
gives me free movie tickets yeah that's
cool yeah I'm so blessed so so blessed I
can't even complain I can't complain
but I'm not going what were your parents
at my mom's yeah my dad's my East Coast
yeah well part of these girls Baltimore
Baltimore I've only been there once that
much to do out there I think when you
live like in California and yeah yeah do
man I'm telling you like I've I was in
um so you know I travel when I do like
these uh these college speaking
engagements and I get to travel to all
these different cities and I every time
I go to a different city I'm like I
[ __ ] love California man what do you
think you'll always live here I will die
here I will die here I'm not going
anywhere
I'm not going anywhere I like visiting
places right but I'm not I'm not trying
to I'm not trying to live anywhere else
man like when I was in New York and I
felt that when sliced through my body
like a hot knife through butter
beautiful yo you know when I was you
know when we were in [ __ ] in Salt
Lake City for for a blizzard for through
the blizzard [ __ ] it was a bit was how
much you want to bet it was blizzard a
you know let's look it up give Lee what
they said they said it was a blizzard
not it was a blizzard are you dressed
inappropriately let me I was 300 pounds
and nothing was getting you that's the
biggest difference I started to
understand is that when I was fat
nothing would affect me yo Kurtis looked
at me like I was insane because I just
had a puff jacket and then like a
long-sleeve t-shirt he was like yo
you're not [ __ ] cold he was I'm
freezing right now it's like aren't you
from New York he was like nah but it's
okay being this bad that's because you
were all hopped up on the [ __ ]
woman's parade of [ __ ] remember it being
this bad it was so fun I almost couldn't
get it uber back because there was no
birds that woke me about yeah it was it
was so it was snowing so hard there it
was it was actually a very odd how hard
it was snowing
but I from our Airbnb we almost couldn't
even make it back get to to Sundance
because it was it was snowing so hard
dan yeah you don't remember any of the
[ __ ] I'm telling you it was a beautiful
magical snow globe experience for me
you are rich there was a [ __ ] Raynor
that was dead on the road you didn't see
that [ __ ]
what it was really [ __ ] cold oh
that's it right there that's the whole
damn pond yes I like talking to you
don't end it whoa still let me kick it
after this yeah we have snacks yeah I
told you though you were so nervous
about this podcast I was i okay I'm
gonna listen to it obviously but I hate
hearing my voice sometimes it's just
like Oh God and I'm doing a voice over
gig how can you hate hearing your voice
you also had that [ __ ] one Instagram
post where you were way way well you had
too much bass in your voice oh my god
such an [ __ ] Maria say why you gonna
give me directions do digital marketing
that's we were just talking about that
see it's about the P C's you respect
them but you don't respect them that
disrespect you that much are you to give
me advice about myself thanks lady say
well the bass in your voice right well
what can they find you on Instagram and
my blog I do dance videos too so if you
wanna see me dancing I know you're only
here my boys here but dancing a lot
lately so it's my little creative outlet
not little let me not minimize it and so
my goal this year is to do six dance
videos like it's one thing that
genuinely brings me joy and I like let
me do this to make myself happy and I
can look at it in 20 years and be like
look how adorable I was just like to
show my kids before you were born
daddies of the time saying oh I should
say you shouldn't say your handle so
it's all Mona talks and then my blog is
all Mona talks calm my name is oh oh
you're gonna write my name
I don't have to spell it spell om o n o
talks calm sidebar there's a river in
Japan with my name sometimes when I'm on
the phone with people they think I'm
Japanese and then they see me and then
they get disappointed oh really yeah
there's a called OMA no I don't know
Japanese be hormonal I was like oh I'll
get your Japanese as well I'm not
Japanese well you should start up your
own feminine Caroline because you're not
Japanese they're like what the [ __ ] is
this [ __ ] she's a [ __ ] African woman
[ __ ] this I hate this it's racist racism
yeah racism boom well guys you guys can
catch us on every single audio platform
out there we're talking about iTunes if
you have if you're watching this on
YouTube leave a bunch of comments below
start up a discussion chat it up and
then we'll see you all next time peace
[Music]